who are those people what are you
wearing why are they here what are you
wearing like our anniversary our
anniversary what
you don't know i'm not going to tell you
is that
it looks like her you move at the speed
of sound and i can make a pen float
through the air who needs to abbreviate
look i know it's been a crazy few years
on this planet but he's dead right
not blipped
dead excellent plan where's the
tenderizer what am i looking at
you what is this where's this coming
from
out there you didn't answer the back
door for your upside-down cage
oh hi
is it authentic i'm not sure how to
answer that is it happening in real time
is recorded fabricated i don't know i
don't know and i don't know what do you
know
my equipment registered an extremely
high level of cmbr that's relic
radiation dating back to the big bang
yeah entwined was a broadcast frequency
so i had your goons pick me up a sweet
vintage tv and when i plug this bad boy
in voila sound and picture dinner is
served
[Music]
so you're saying the universe created a
sitcom starring two avengers
it's a working theory